Salut ! Ce soir c'était les Hallucinations Collectives, vous savez le plateau que je fais 1 fois par mois, et
Pour cette édition, la n°6, j'avais invité un magicien qui s'appelle Tao
C'est un mec qui mélange la magie, le Kung-fu. Vous l'avez peut être vu sur "Incroyable Talent"
Et vous savez ce que je fais maintenant quand j'ai un magicien avec moi ?
Je le fais bosser à ma place !
Salut Tao ! -Bonsoir Tout le monde, merci Fabien de m'inviter chez toi !
- Est-ce que tu peux me faire un tour de magie ? Evidémment je ne suis pas complice
Sinon ca n'a aucun intêret...
Je me mets derrière vous comme ca, vous allez voir avec mes yeux !
-Je sais que vous connaissez tous les tours de cartes. Mais on va faire quelque chose d'un peu original.
Je ne sais pas si tu le verras à la caméra, ce petit sachet, ce n'est pas... c'est du VRAI Sucre !
Je peux te le passer Fabien, tu peux le tenir en attendant ? -C'est bon !
-Parfait ! On va te faire choisir une carte rapidement, classiquement.
Tu m'arrêtes, comme tes deux mains sont prises... - Stop ! - C'est bon là ? -Ouai !
Je la montre à la caméra comme ça ? -C'est bon, je ne dis pas la carte donc. -Tu ne l'as dis pas.
Tu la montres juste à tes amis de YouTube !
- Ils sont milliers ! Ils sont légions !
-Je ne te regarde pas, je rentre la carte parce qu'il y a des miroirs derrière toi. Je suis honnête !
Je mets ce jeu à l'intérieur, pas de triche... En slow motion, in the pocket !
-C'est pas sympa, je filme tout en gros plan ! [Rire] - C'est ce qu'on appelle du Close-up en même temps !
-Pourquoi ce sachet de sucre ? Une recette de grand-mère dit que,
On peut prédire l'avenir dans du Marc de Café, comme au théatre il n'y en a pas, on prend ce sachet !
Je fais tout, comme tu as les mains prises? Parce qu'il faut déchirer le sachet. - Oui, je te le laisse faire...
-Délicatement, je laisse tomber, on a pas de table. Est-ce que je peux te faire passer le briquet ? -Bien sûr !
Regarde, je serre bien le poing pour pas que le sucre ne puisse s'échapper. J'en verse un peu sur mon poing, Il remplace le marc de café.
C'est bon ? C'est du véritable sucre !
Parfait ! C'est bon ? -Oui -Je vais d'abord te demander de penser à la valeur.
Si c'est du Pique du Trèfle, du Coeur ou du Carreau.
-C'est bon, j'ai la valeur -d'accord, donc je rajoute un peu de sucre.Je pense que c'est une carte basse, ca suffira !
J'enlève le sachet, tu peux faire des gros plans si tu veux. Si tu penses fortement à la carte.
Le briquet va me servir à chauffer la matière, je chauffe en dessous, pas trop...
Je ne vois pas du tout où tu veux en venir...
-Tu peux prendre le briquet, s'il te plaît. Tu te souviens de la symbolique de ta carte, tu peux nous le dire !
-Coeur ! -Regardes bien dans ma main. Si on chauffe un peu la matière, ça solidifie le coeur, et voilà !
Je ne sais pas si tu arrives à voir... -Ah, si !
Maintenant que je sais que c'est du Coeur, c'est toi qui va faire la magie, tends ta main Fabien.
Je te le mets au bout des doigts, filme bien pour voir qu'il n'y a pas de triche. C'est bon ? -Oui !
-Il n'y a rien d'autre dans mes 2 mains là... Je vais te demander de fermer ta main et de serrer bien fort.
Tu vas penser fortement, vraiment à la carte entière. -j'y pense, j'y pense !
Voilà très bien, je claque des doigts. Dans un instant tu vas pouvoir ouvrir les mains, comme un vrai magicien,
Mais avant ca tu peux me dire la carte que tu as choisi?
-C'est le 4 de coeur.
Ouvre, tout doucement, pour voir qu'il n'y a pas de triche. Et, ici en rouge, tu as bien le 4 de coeur.
-Le 4 de coeur ! -Exact !!
Je sais que tu ne peux pas applaudir comme tu as la caméra. - Bravo !
-Merci à toi Fabien ! Ecoute, j'applaudis, en direction de l'écran ! - Et, 2ième effet kiss-cool
Et juste pour terminer, je te donne le coeur ici, Pour te prouver que c'était bien ce coeur, ton choix.
Je te mets le jeu, je mets ma main dessus, je pose le sucre dessus, il y'a une réaction chimique.
On enlève une carte, Malgré les coupes et mélanges. Bon là c'est le joker qui remplace n'importe quelle carte.
-Tu t'en sors bien ! On claque un coup, la réaction qui se passe, Je ne sais pas si on voit, Toutes les cartes sont devenues transparentes.
Sauf une, une carte et une seule ! Le 4 de coeur !
-Comme par hasard ! Et pas n'importe lequel, ca fait ta pub si tu le retournes, pour le Mental Vlog !
-Ce mec est un commercial ! Merci Bravo Tao !  Merci de ton invitation J'espère que ça vous a plu,
Que ce n'était pas trop long - Ce n'est jamais trop long, c'est 5 minutes !
Vous pouvez retrouver Tao sur sa page Facebook, je vous mets le lien dans les commentaires.
C'est la deuxième fois sur les Hallucinations Collectives, ce n'est pas la dernière !
Abonnez-vous à la chaine ! Rendez vous demain 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog, Ciao ! [Outro]